how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder i'm your host warren
thompson and d23 is right around the
corner now most of us are still coming
down from the high that we got off of
all of the reveals from marvel studios
at san diego comic con where they
revealed all of phase five or at least
they made it seem like they revealed all
of phase five there could be more coming
from that and they revealed three
projects from phase six which of course
is the fantastic four and then of course
they revealed the two new avengers films
coming avengers the kang dynasty and
avengers secret wars and today it has
been officially announced that marvel
studios will be attending d23 of course
we knew this was going to happen this
was a no-brainer but they made the
official announcement today so let's
talk about what to expect from marvel
studios now i did a couple of videos on
what these projects in phase six could
be that's not what we're talking about
today we're talking about realistically
what is marvel going to actually reveal
to us and of course i know what
everybody is hoping for i'm hoping for
it too and that is x-men news i'll talk
about if i think we're going to get some
x-men news but also news about the
fantastic four i think some pretty big
news is coming up for them which could
be the casting reveal and although i
would hope that they would reveal the
rest of phase six at d23 we really never
can be sure but i do know that there
should be one project revealed at d23
for phase six that has not been revealed
yet so first and foremost let's talk
about the fantastic four news before
diving into this other project and
diving into the x-men because of course
we had john krasinski in the mcu as mr
fantastic reed richards now of course he
was not in our main
616 universe however they announced
secret wars we know that even if john
krasinski does not play our main mr
fantastic he can still show up again in
secret wars obviously not the same one
that we saw in multiverse of madness
because he's kind of spaghetti right now
but a different version that could be
played by john krasinski but will he be
playing the main mr fantastic in the
earth 616 universe well two things about
this one is that recently john krasinski
went on jimmy fallon and he kind of gave
us some teases it was the first time he
went on since multiverse of madness of
course they were talking about him
playing reed richards and in a typical
marvel actor fashion he could not say
anything he just joked around a lot
jimmy i'm gonna tell you on your show
oh my gosh someone killed him right now
can we get a medic
that's that's that's acting right there
no it's actually a marvel dart there's
a dart there's a guy walking around he
then was asked about his wife because of
course as most people know fans have
really been wanting him to play mr
fantastic and his wife emily blunt to
play the invisible woman so jimmy fallon
asked him about that and this is what he
said yeah and there's also a rumor that
uh your wife uh emily blunt will play
sue storm oh making the first hus
you think
you think
so obviously he can't really answer he
even makes the joke about somebody from
marvel studios shooting him with a dart
in the neck knocking him out but i do
believe that this could be used to build
up hype for d23 where we could be
getting an official announcement which
is the second thing rumors have been
going around that we are indeed set for
a fantastic four casting announcement at
d23 now i want to reiterate this is a
rumor it is not confirmed but if we
actually take a second and think about
this it would make sense for them to
announce the cast if they have the cast
already picked however they have given
us the release date for the fantastic
four and given this timeline it seems
like marvel studios should have already
chosen the cast the official release
date for the fantastic four coming to
the mcu is november 8th of 2024 we are
almost in november of 2022 just a few
months away which means that the
fantastic four is basically two years
away and that's about how long it takes
to make a movie especially a really big
one like the fantastic four and we do
know that kevin feige is putting a lot
of his time into the fantastic four
because it is a very important project
to him so from the start from the
concept to getting screenwriters
directors producers getting the script
written pre-production principle
photography and post-production that all
takes about two years and since kevin
feige considers this so important to him
it would make sense that the cast would
have already been picked after all
consider this taran egerton the other
day opened up and said that he met with
marvel studios four years ago about
playing cyclops in the mcu that's before
the deal with fox was even done or at
least was right around when it got
finished that would have been casting
way in advance like years upon years so
it's definitely likely that the
fantastic four have been cast for the
mcu already and we'll talk about taran
egerton and the x-men in just a bit but
as far as a huge announcement for d23 we
know that marvel studios needed to save
some really big things for d23 which is
crazy considering they announced two new
avengers films at sdcc that is huge
that's pretty much as big as it gets so
what other huge news could they release
at d23 well of course the two biggest
things that we think of are the
fantastic forecast and of course the
x-men now if you recall at sdcc of 2019
which was the last sdcc that marvel
studios attended before this last one
the last thing that kevin feige talked
about was the fantastic four and the
mutants now we got our fantastic four
news they gave us the release date and
hopefully we get casting as well but we
got nothing about the x-men or the
mutants however that could change at d23
that could be the big announcement that
marvel studios was saving for this event
now based off of what taryn edgarton has
said it looks like marvel studios has
been planning for the x-men for a very
long time in an interview in two
separate interviews actually he said
that he met with marvel studios four
years ago apparently kevin feige was
talking to him about playing cyclops in
the mcu he turned it down because he
didn't want to play a character and
commit to that character for a number of
years who had his eyes covered the
entire time this is great news this
means that kevin feige has been working
on the x-men project in the mcu for
years now it's also good news for the
fantastic four like i mentioned but
since kevin feige has been working on
the x-men for years that probably means
that he knows when he wants the x-men to
debut and heck it could even be in phase
6. think about this if you know the
story of secret wars you know that it
involves everybody but not just
everybody everybody and their variants
the fantastic four play a huge part but
we know they're coming before secret
wars but the x-men also do play a big
part as well and marvel knows that this
event is going to be absolutely huge and
the x-men slash mutants need to be there
which is why they have introduced kamala
khan as the mcu's first mutant now not
too long ago kevin feige did say we're
going to start to see where everything
is going not too long after that they
introduced kamala khan as the first
mutant and now they introduced all of
this at sdcc and we have a lot to talk
about at d23 it seems like an x-men
announcement is coming it seems like
that is going to be the big big reveal
at d23 especially if they're going to be
a part of the mcu before secret wars and
yes i have heard the stuff about the
contract of not being able to use the
x-men until 2025 but theoretically if
it's a general fox contract for the fox
marvel characters that should apply to
the fantastic four as well and the
fantastic four coming in 2024 so that
contract might not be all what we think
it is plus not to mention kevin feige
was trying to cast cyclops four years
ago so that doesn't seem to be too much
of an issue so fingers crossed for a
x-men slash mutant announcement at d23
and just so everybody is aware d23 is
from september 9th to september 11th now
a project that has been announced but
has not yet been revealed is a nova
project and recently some insiders have
stated that we should be getting the
nova project before
secret wars and the king dynasty this
means that nova is indeed a part of
phase six and even if they aren't going
to reveal completely and entirely phase
six i do still think that we'll get that
nova announcement because that has
already been announced by the major
trades out there like deadline and
hollywood reporter and after the
announcement everybody was talking about
it so we all essentially know about it
by now and there were some rumors that
ryan gosling could be playing nova and
recently kevin feige was talking about
how he would love to find a place in the
mcu for ryan gosling because he thinks
he's amazing now of course he's not just
going to come out and say oh yeah ryan
gosling's great he's going to play nova
he obviously can't say that if he's
already been casted but if they have
already got a nova i would expect an
announcement for the movie and a casting
announcement as well now the last thing
i think we can realistically expect is
the director announcement for avengers
secret wards we already know that destin
daniel [ __ ] the director of shanxi and
the legend of the ten rings is going to
be directing the king dynasty zhang chi
is in my top 5 favorite mcu movies now i
think that movie is amazing so i think
this is a great choice and i know a lot
of people want the russo brothers to
come back and direct secret wars they've
talked plenty of times about what it
would take for them to come back to the
mcu and they've always said secret wars
or a wolverine project and secret wars
kind of gives them the opportunity to do
both since the x-men should be in secret
wars now again kevin feige and the russo
brothers have said that nope the russos
aren't directing secret wars but again
they can't come out and say it but since
we have a director for the kang dynasty
i'm assuming we have a director for
secret wars and i'm assuming that if
that's true we do get an announcement
for it at d23 so realistically i think
this is what we can expect of course
along with some other project reveals
hopefully we get that fantastic
forecasting announcement hopefully we
get something about the mutants and i'm
hoping we get an actor announcement for
nova but let me know what you are most
excited for in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof